okay let's go to the 209 area code
caller from 209 I don't know where 209
is maybe you can tell us where you're
calling from and what's on your mind
California okay I didn't catch your name
what was it Victor Victor okay go ahead
Victor there's a question for a fat oh
wow okay my yeah I was planning on going
vegan and I just want to know if you
have any preferred cheese substitutes
there's like a diet cheese you can use
that's a that's a brand diet cheese I
achieve oh I say why are you on a diet
no da I why a but largely I don't use
cheese substitutes I know you can make a
cheese out of cashews as well which may
be a surprise to you David yes it's like
a cashew buffalo mozzarella really good
okay that is it was that your only vegan
related question Victor yeah pretty much
what I do like our cream cheese
substitutes and tofu D makes an awesome
cream cheese alternative are you in the
tofurkey planet as well occasionally you
know sometimes get lazy with cooking
yeah I don't want to go home and make
this entire meal so it's just the easy
thing to do put together a little
sandwich yep you know Victor how soon
are you thinking of making this
transition maybe like tomorrow a week or
so how long have you been talking about
it how long have you been thinking about
it about a month about a month
interesting and your whole life you've
been a meat-eater yeah heavy meat eater
actually and what happened a month ago
that made you start thinking about
veganism well a few months ago I started
weightlifting and I've heard a lot of
benefits about going vegan and and
weightlifting so that's trying to you
know just try it out I've been I've been
reading also about how some weight
lifters get huge returns this is gonna
be crazy but from drinking their own
urine like is that something you're also
considering Victor I've never heard
about that okay yeah Google that you can
find stuff out about that alright that's
do you think that's switching to
veganism will be easy for your lifestyle
or difficult um I mean where I live
vegetables are pretty cheap so mmm I
think it'll be pretty easy and you're
not doing that vegetarian thing in the
middle of the transition as well you're
going straight for a meat-eater to vegan
we heard that oh I'm sorry if you might
have never heard pat pat was wondering
whether you you might go first to
vegetarianism before veganism um
maybe that'll be that'll ease the
transition I guess yeah yeah no I would
just make sure that you get enough
calories because plant foods tend to
have a like low caloric percentage yep
so you got to make sure that you're
getting even past when you're full yes
even if you're full you just got to keep
eating Victor that's a lesson horn
honking Pat so uh all right we'll let it
call back in let us know how it's going
if you do it all right
okay no problem all right excellent that
was a nice little call to round things
out we will take a break and we've got
some really good audience questions
coming up next